that's a serious serious advantage
[Music]
welcome to the final episode in Ag guide
to need for speed payback brought to you
by EA and in this final one we're gonna
get a bit competitive and we're gonna
get a little bit are we gonna do this
yeah extreme because we have found so
many amazing jumps around the airfield
that naturally one of us wants to reign
supreme as the king of the air so we're
gonna take three jumps and the airfield
and whoever gets the farthest is the
winner
yelling you with me you ready I was born
ready the first time we're tackling now
this is something you may not have seen
throughout the videos but this jump has
been taunting us on pretty much every
load screen we've seen throughout the
game is that there's a beautiful ramp
just on the side of this derelict jumbo
jet so I'm going to take first stab at
this let's give it a go
no no nudging no no mind games gone 95
95 yards respectable it's not a vehicle
that was built to flight 95 yards to be
yeah let's go baby it's all about the
judicious application of that night show
if you nail that at the right time I
think that was a bit premature oh I was
there leaving little bit too early 30 40
yards
I built the speed early so we had the
continuation my friend I would no
pressure
don't let me down now camo van there we
go sweet bit of boost just to top that
one fly again wobbles a bit 99 oh that's
a three star jump are we really yeah
okay so I play see dragged out a little
bits there's a bit of reduced visibility
because the sun's gone down I've got
this at my junk
like a little bit off-center there with
your shaky or what's this a serious
serious advantage Oh a dog ran out in
front of me
so after Yanni's like slightly
disastrous second jump we've agreed that
I'm gonna try and attempt this final
jump in Reverse just so there's some
chance of you winning yeah yeah here we
go
go yangdon go one miles an hour doing
nicest working with this no it doesn't
look does not compute
you can do it seven seven yards that's
not bad you're gonna win
you ready already the liver B can't
believe I did that I should have just
taken the easy path yes I've got two one
that 93 yards 93 93 yards we've got a
defer to our adjudicator that's 197
siannie
201 to me flawless victory well play
right I missed the ramp the only way
you're gonna win by me missing the ramp
and on that bombshell that concludes a
guy to need for speed payback Yanni
thank you so much for joining me across
these videos even an absolute pleasure
what an amazing way to go out I'm so
happy how about you how do you feel I
feel great any final words good night